Have you ever noticed how sending
off these update requests
feels a little like you're sending
messages off to the Firebase void,
unsure whether they're complete or
are received?
>> There.
>> Hello, are you there?
Lila, are you there?
Okay, well,
at least you're still connected.
Let's talk about completion callbacks.
One aspect of writing data we haven't
discussed is the completion callback.
Completion callbacks are useful
if you want to explicitly
return the status of
a completed write operation.
For example, if you use a completion
callback when a write is successful or
fails, an object will be returned
describing the success, or
in the event of an error,
failure of that write.
For example, if you use a completion
callback when a write is successful or
fails, an object will be returned
describing the success or
in the event of an error
failure of that right.
We aren't using completion
callbacks in ShoppingList ++.
However there are a few situations
where using completion callbacks
would be useful.
A basic use would be to provide detailed
debugging information in the dev and
test phase.
For example, to provide an explicit way
to verify that data is being saved.
Another use would be to use a completion
callback to fire when a value is
returned that is outside of a threshold.
As a comparison,
have you ever seen the all changes
save to drive message in Google Docs?
It doesn't hurt to provide users with
a little assurance that their data has
been saved to the cloud.
Similarly, sometimes chat programs will
tell you when the message has been sent
to the other user.